one of the things that's very important
to understand about South Africa is that
it is like so many other African
countries an artificial entity created
by the Brits the South Africa that we
know in its present borders is only a
hundred and four years old in 1990 when
we went through our transition it was
only 80 years old it was the creation of
the British Empire Britain acquired
possession of most of the territories of
South southern Africa in the 19th
century and what won a one historian
referred to as a fit of
absent-mindedness at the beginning of
the century had found itself in
possession with a ragbag of territories
which were difficult to manage and very
expensive the whole of the 19th century
had been about the British conquest of
southern Africa first of the closer
people in nine wars of the acts that
finally led to in 1856 to a national
suicide by that closer people where they
decided that they would kill their
cattle and destroy their crops on the
advice of a prophetess who said that if
they did this the British would be
driven into the sea of course they
weren't and tens of thousands of cause
of people died the second major people
who were conquered in the 19th century
by the Brits with the Zulus Zulus had
been the dominant tribe and southeastern
Africa after the foundation of their
nation by their great King Shaka the
British settled what is now the natal
province of South Africa and they
brought in white settlers and and
Indians to work on sugar farms but they
were very nervous about this powerful
Zulu Kingdom to the north of them there
to gehler River and so they found a
reason to declare war against
the Zulus and to their enormous surprise
at the Battle of schlonged Juana
and 7th and 1878 a whole British army
was wiped out 1,500 men this was just a
few years after the Little Bighorn but
it's five times as big and the the Zulus
wiped out a whole British army of course
the Brits sent more troops and they were
they defeated the King Cetshwayo
and the next year in 1879 the third
people that the Brits conquered were the
Afrikaners or the Brewers who'd been
settled in South Africa since 1652 they
didn't like British rule so in the 19th
century they trekked into the interior
they founded two Republic's the republic
of the Orange Free State and the
Republic of the Trance fall but then the
people in the Free State made the big
mistake of discovering the biggest
diamond lode in history at Kimberley so
the Brits annexed that and then in the
1880s the Transformer Republic made the
huge mistake of discovering the biggest
gold bearing body in the world the the
famous Johannesburg reef and the result
of this was that the British again
sought a pretext for war with these two
Republic's and that led to the
anglo-boer war in 1899 now anglo-boer
war was the biggest war that the British
fought between the Napoleonic Wars and
the first world war they deployed over
four hundred and thirty eight thousand
imperial troops in South Africa they
conquered the two territories and then
having taken them over at the beginning
of the 20th century they didn't know
what to do with him
so they looked around the Empire said
Orwell look in Canada we had this
Dominion we had a federation there
that's worked very well we did it in
Australia at different states we created
a federation there why don't we do that
in southern Africa so they did but they
decide
to keep some territories in and some
territories out they included the Zulus
and the causes in the new society but
they gave control of the new country the
Union of South Africa which was
established in 1910 to the whites
because at that time black people in
Africa throughout the world didn't
really have political rights so for most
of the 20th century the big question in
South Africa was not the relationship
between whites and blacks that the
relationship between english-speaking
whites and afrikaans-speaking whites and
the afrikaans-speaking whites wanted to
re-establish their republics that was
the driving force behind the National
Party which came to power in 1948
now they then instituted although not
racial segregation they gave it a new
name apartheid and it was straight
forward racial domination that before we
become too morally self-righteous that
is what was happening in the rest of
Africa unacceptable indefensible it was
what was happening in the South and the
United States at the time undefensible
in unacceptable but it wasn't unusual
then Africa started moving toward
independence with Ghana in 1957 a new
Prime Minister came to power in in 1958
called henrik french for vote and he
thought okay right the British and the
French are decolonizing in Africa will
do the same here this country's only 60
years old so we'll give the Zulu bits
back to the Zulus will give the closer
bits back to the causes and the other
national groups and he had this great
idea of of unscrambling the south and
south african omelet that was called
separate development everybody would be
able to develop to the top level in
their own societies
and this way whites would it would be
able to retain a right to national
self-determination that they had always
had unfortunately he was a sociologist
and do never never put sociologists in
charge of countries because they will do
social engineering and this is a really
good example of the the negative effects
of social engineering the idea was okay
look we got too many blacks here let's
move them over here you know they don't
want to but you can't make an omelet
without breaking eggs and that was I
think where a lot of the hardship in
South Africa under part under apartheid
came from but it was an illusion there
was no way that you were going to
unscramble this omelet and unscramble
the eggs economic growth was bringing
more and more South Africans together in
the economy in the so-called white areas
so it was a delusion and revolt was
assassinated in 1966 his successor John
Foster continued with his delusion for
the next ten years twelve years until he
was replaced by a guy called PW Witter
PW Berta said look this isn't working
we're going to have to reform this so he
was a reformer by 1986 he'd abolished a
hundred apartheid laws including some of
the most repulsive mixed marriages
legislation limiting the ability of
black South Africans to move from one
place to the other he looked at the
political rights of the colored and my
and Indian minorities and adopted a new
constitution in 1983 in terms of which
coloreds and Indians were brought into
the same polity as whites but of course
that all of this raised the question and
focused the question on the right of
black South Africans
- political self-determination so at the
beginning of the 1980s white South
Africans found themselves riding a tiger
the tiger was a an increasingly
articulate and increasingly economically
aware black population the rest of the
world was shouting at South Africa get
off the tiger
the problem with riding a tiger is
actually how you dismounted because the
audience isn't really concerned whether
you're going to get eaten or not and
white South Africans had concerns they
were concerned about the fact that they
had a right to self-determination the
Afrikaners had for a hundred and two
hundred years striven to rule themselves
they didn't want to rule anybody else
the question was how would they be able
to maintain their right to national
self-determination in a one-man one-man
one-vote dispensation in South Africa
the second problem was the fact that
democracy one man one vote elections
hadn't worked very well in the rest of
Africa at that stage I think by the
mid-1980s there'd been more than 90 coup
d'etats
and the rest of Africa so a lot of
whites were worried look
yeah they the rest of the world tells us
to get off the tiger but if we do that
we have one election and then we have
chaos and then a third great concern was
the role of the South African Communist
Party within the ANC during the 1970s
and 1980s virtually all of the members
of the ANC's National Executive
Committee were also members of the South
African Communist Party and we knew that
the Communist Party had adopted a
two-phase revolutionary process and this
was the classic Soviet model throughout
the world first phase of the process
is called a national liberation and it
takes place under the aegis of the
national liberation movement which
unites all factions in society opposed
to the regime it leads society to the
national national liberation that at
that stage the Communist Party takes
over as the vanguard of the process and
leads on toward the establishment of a
communist state why we weren't too keen
about this that it wasn't just a
question of Reds under beds the Soviet
Union was really interested in expanding
its influence in South Africa in the
Cold War the main theater of activity
was proxy wars
sponsored by the Soviet Union and in
third world countries so we had the
problem of 50,000 Cuban troops and to
the north of us and Angola we had on the
East a Mozambique and communist
government very closely allied to the
Soviet Union so we were very worried
about the about the the communist
dimension in all of this but then as he
progressed PW would have found out that
it wasn't going to be possible to reform
about it he couldn't really bring
himself to accept that a new South
Africa would have to be on a one-man
one-vote basis that it would not be
possible for whites to maintain any kind
of sovereignty within the new South
Africa because they were nowhere close
to being in a majority but this is
something that he couldn't really accept
during this period however huge debate
was taking place in the ruling National
Party and by the mid-1980s by 1987 1988
it had been accepted that we really
needed transformation rather than reform
and PW Berto
I don't think was a student of de
Tocqueville he didn't realize that
revolutions take place in situations of
rising expectations that it's when
states begin to reform that they really
take the lid off the pressure cooker and
that's what had happened in South Africa
so we had widespread unrest and protests
in the 8th in the 1984 1985 we had a
state of emergency in 1986 which put the
lid back on but the National Party
leadership then realized that look there
was not going to be any way of doing
this without transformation and that's
when de Klerk became the leader of the
National Party and in in February 1989
after PW Boyd had suffered from a stroke
de Klerk in his first speech that we
need a totally changed South Africa when
he became president in September 1989 he
immediately moved toward normalizing the
situation he allowed protests in the
street much to the delight of Archbishop
Tutu he released the all of the
remaining high-profile ANC prisoners
except Mandela he held talks with
Mandela and then on the 2nd of February
1990 he made a speech in Parliament in
which he opened the way to negotiations
he put it all on the table at once this
was very important because he surpassed
expectations and it meant that we could
get the ball rolling in terms of a
negotiation process the ANC was taken
unawares on the I think the 9th of
February
he had a clerk had a meeting with mr.
Mandela who was then a prisoner but
under raised favorable circumstances he
had his own house and so forth he said
mr. Mandela
where
releasing you on Sunday in two days and
and president mr. Mandela's response was
no you can't possibly do that we do not
have enough time to make a reference and
the clerk said look we have to do it
then but you can choose where you want
to be released in Johannesburg or Cape
Town and that was the first of many many
compromises that were made in the
subsequent negotiations the factors that
made the negotiations possible included
the following first of all by 1987 all
sides to the conflict had accepted that
there would not be an armed solution our
own security forces which were very
powerful realized that you could not
maintain the situation through armed
force forever
we could have kept on for another two or
three decades but under really negative
circumstances the ANC realized there
wasn't going to be a revolutionary
outcome and it's only when parties
accept that there will not be an armed
outcome that you can have genuine
negotiations something that hasn't
happened yet for example in the Middle
East so that was the first green traffic
light then in 1988 in fact in September
1987 our armed forces were involved in
very severe conflict in battles with
Cuban and Russian led forces in southern
Angola the Battle of the Lamba River was
probably the biggest set piece battle in
Africa since the second world war more
than 5000 Angolan troops died in that
battle hardly covered at all in the
international media but what did what it
meant was that the Russians got tired of
trying to find an armed solution
in southern Africa Gorbachev was more
interested in perestroika and glasnost
and that was the turning of the tide so
in 1988 there was an international
agreement between the Angolans the
Cubans and the Americans regarding the
withdrawal of the 50,000 Cuban troops
from Angola this opened the way for the
independence of Namibia immediately to
the south of Angola that South Africa
had ruled since 1915 under a League of
Nations mandate the elections were
supervised by the UN they worked well
what it proved was that positive
outcomes should could be achieved in
negotiations even with one's bitterest
enemies provided there's a proper
constitutional framework so that was
traffic light 2 & 3 turning green
underlying all of this there had been
huge shifts in economic relationships
social relationships in the 70s and 80s
in 1970 black South Africans share of
personal disposable income in South
Africa was only about 20% White's share
was 72 percent the rest was colored and
Asian but by 1994 the white share had
fallen to under 50 percent black share
was up around 38 percent coloreds and
Asians the rest and this meant that
relationships had changed also quite
dramatically the economy could not be
run on the basis of the white workers
alone at the end of the 1970s we had to
make our first really big reforms and
they were labor reforms and they gave
genuine trade union rights to black
South Africans but that also increased
the bargaining power of black South
Africans incomes rose
and the economy became much more
integrated and you had more and more
black kids coming into the economy at
higher and higher levels so in your
average blank you would have had black
tellers and white tellers doing the same
jobs working beside one another there's
no way they're going to go to segregated
dining rooms
there's no way ultimately they're going
to go to segregated places of
entertainment so it was a question of of
economic forces changing social
relationships putting unbearable
pressure on outmoded constitutional
relationships and that in fact has been
the process of development throughout
the world